il a su répondre abolissons
universellement le malheur de douleur et
n'allez pas john may cry madame
entendent aller il n'y a pas de mots
pour décrire cet abominable ce type là
dedans je suis comme à celle attendue
courant qu'en plus des moqueries est une
expression juste et la colère également
jeu sidec ce qui n'est pas juste c'est
le ton modéré
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
possibilité quand nous sommes dans la
fin du monde
nous sommes dans l'au delà des mots nous
sommes dans la banalité du mal comme
l'autorisé à l'arrêt s'il vous plaît
chez moi là nous sommes dans la banalité
du match tu faisais dorsale bon se lever
dans l'est comme la main deux minutes
est une torture leur place mais là vous
allez vous battre avec elle on verra si
on combine dément je sais c'est en nous
sommes en situation d'un chat crime et
du post traumatique tous seuls breaks la
distance en mode combat mais c'est au
delà de notre vie c'est bien que je me
fous du bon ton à plateaux télé rien
nous sommes au delà
on utilise le pire interrompant le pire
reprenons la résistance là où elles
servent à lausanne wade c'est bon là
stop un peu plus vague à sont pas voir
la vie non
baptiste allez-y vous entend plus les
autres alors on s'en régale donc alors
oui alors ce qu'il souhaite c'est que
effectivement le ce que montre l214 je
pense que c'est utile est en fait une
version pas si je le soutiens je
soutiens une force grâce à un écran ça
coûte cher et grands sacs étaient pas ça
c'est une histoire de leur combat est
utile c'est vrai parce qu'il faut que
les français voient ça aussi parce que
danton dépensé se cacher les yeux
vis-à-vis de ça c'est vrai oui que 80%
des abattoirs en france c'est ça ou le
comprendre et c'est toute la chaîne
agroalimentaire qu'il faut changer de
l'élevage à l'abattage pas encore
résistants de vrais résistants pas comme
l214
vous avez des éleveurs qui travaille
correctement si vous avez encore des
abattoirs filière française des
abattoirs l'analyse et qui endorment les
animaux d'accord avant de les abattre il
existait à bateau et je connais que je
connais et tétouan de seconde peau
gesetz déjà que je rappelle qu'il fait
mener par 3 qui partent de l'oise de
gueule du loup val d'oise pour aller
jusqu'au bout de la picardie trouver un
abattoir il passe devant trois abattoirs
avant de trouver un abattoir correct
pour et leurs bêtes il ya deux éleveurs
qui font ce travail là il faut les
valoriser ce qu'il faut expliquer aux
français c'est
vous voyez des pubs qui vous disent de 0
2 kg de côte de porc il faut que les
français comprennent que quand ils
achètent ce prix là c'est ça qu'ils
achètent et il faut pas les il faut pas
les traumatiser comme vous le savez il
faut pas leur imputer les droits lui de
pouvoir dont il s'envole pour proposer
un label une mort c'est une mort comblés
bal est ouvert à tous la nature est
fluide nature fn alimentaire on comprend
on comprend ce qu'il ya dans le regard
mais ces pillages
moi je moi moi j'ai jamais dit non mais
t'es déjà arrêter d'inventer des moutons
c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui tous les scientifiques le
disent parce que laurent coste débat est
arrêté dans c'est pas possible mais la
direction avait délation mais du mar
dans les mails à vous faites c'est
contre-productif même pourrait-on pilar
c'est vous aidera à changer les choses
complexes allez je vous sais pas la
colère ne marche pas le calme ne marche
pas c'est baptiste six prisonniers
notamment la police qui n'ont pas ici
voilà qui nous met en prison les i
messieurs dames vous êtes seul vous êtes
une bande de séniors et vous la colère
ne sera jamais au niveau sonore est bon
de dire tu dois tout apprécié
les sujets nationaux il faut abolir
universellement le second dry le règne
de m possesseurs qui ont vu six millions
d'individus
ces machines à produire de la viande
c'était loin c'est le soldat a été sacré
toutes ses nuances et cerisiers marathon
geste hâtif
on l'a désormais près de danse ont
soulevé les règles et c'est parler les
autres ses congénères dans les camps
d'exécution des caméras qu'est ce que ça
change
conférence n'a fait mauvais genre ce
magot grec sol de gaza gassier vous si
vous plongez maféré quand même c'est pas
ce soir paris sortait du bon temps c'est
pas ce soir c'est une fois demande qui
s'orchestre avenue jean-moulin pandémie
vient de la vue du masque du vaccin vous
êtes ridicule on vient des épisodes
aussi les éleveurs sont des provocateurs
de doula des provocateurs de maladie
c'est un peu long pour les gens curieux
arrêtez avec moi moi je retiens un truc
de ce que vous avez dit baptiste et là
je rejoins sur le bec sur laquelle sur
ce qu'elle va le dire parce que oui
solberg son combat alors solberg elle
était victime
je ne sais pas enfermé toute la journée
à l'envahir gb 10 baptistes moi et c'est
vrai qu'on est nombreux à rejoindre l'un
combat détruit bien sûr sévir le biais
de solveig aussi évident vrai ou pas non
mais non mais c'est vrai mais le sourire
donc vous avez dit un truc c'est que 80%
des abattoirs ne respectent pas les
règles et c'est ça le même ceux qui
respectent les règles suprême soutien et
ce mec les règles l'afrique sont
compliquées pour un vrai qu on dise que
loco locass et qui est comme ça
non non non mais ça